مع دخول المعارك اسبوعها الثاني القتال
يشتد رغم الهدنه المعلنه في السودان
اشتباكات بين الجيش وقوات الدعم السريع في
محيط القصر الرئاسي وسط العاصمه الخرطوم
وضربات جويه قرب هيئه الاذاعه والتلفزيون
ومعارك بالاسلحه الناريه في مناطق عده
وهجمات متبادله في ام درمان وانفجارات
عنيفه والسنه لهب في الخرطوم بحري
في مؤشر على اخفاق جهود وقف اطلاق النار
بدو اولى عمليات الاجلاء لمدنيين منذ بدء
الاشتباكات عواصم اوروبيه تخطط لاجلاء
الرعايه رئيس الوزراء البريطاني رئيس
اجتماعا طارئا والولايات المتحده وكوريا
الجنوبيه واليابان تنشر قوات في دول
مجاوره استعدادا لاجلاء محتمل
[موسيقى]
الامم المتحده تكشف عن زياده كبيره في
عمليات النزوح الصليب الاحمر الدولي يحذر
من نفاد الماء والغذاء لدى ملايين
المدنيين المحاصرين في منازلهم كاميرا
الجزيره ترصد ازمه المستشفيات جراء
المعارك وفي بوادر ازمه لاجئين برنامج
الاغذيه العالميه توقع وصول الاف
السودانيين لمناطق حضوريه في تشاد
نقل مراسل الجزيره ان الطائرات حربيه حلقت
في جنوب الخرطوم بحري وان قوه الدعم
السريع استخدمت مضادات الطيران لمحاوله
اسقاطها ونفى الجيش السوداني ما اعلنته
قوات الدعم السريع عن سيطرتها على موقع
مدينه جياد الصناعيه في الخرطوم وقال انه
لا وجود حاليا لمن وصفهم بالمتمردين في
المدينه الصناعيه هذا ويشهد محيط القياده
العامه للجيش السوداني في العاصمه اطلاق
نار مستمرا
هذا وافاد مراسل الجزيره في الخرطوم ان
عدد من العسكريين والمدنيين قتلوا خلال
اشتباكات عنيفه بالاسلحه الثقيله والخفيفه
في حي شامبات شماليه الخرطوم بحري كما
سقطت قذائف طائشه على المساكن وشهدت
سيارات عسكريه محترقه بجانبها جثث عند
منطقه السوق المركزي بينما اشتعلت النيران
في المحاله التجاريه وجزء من ابراج سكن
ضباط الشرطه واستقبل المستشفى الدولي
بالخرطوم بحري سبعه جرحه مدنيين حسب مصدر
طبي قال للجزيره ان المستشفى اضطر
لاحالتهم الى مستشفيات اخرى بسبب نقص
اختصاصي الجراحه
وكان مراسل الجزيره افاد باحتدام المعارك
بمختلف انواع الاسلحه بين الجيش السوداني
وقوه الدعم السريع في محيط القصر الرئاسي
والقياده العامه للجيش كما سمع دوي
انفجارات وشهدت اعمده دخان كثيف بعد سقوط
قذائف في مناطق مثل حله حمد وخوجلي غربيه
مدينه الخرطوم بحري
وفي منطقه كرري شماليه اندرمان افلت مصادر
محليه للجزيره بسماع دوي فيجارات وتحليق
لطائره الحربيه في المنطقه واشارت مصادر
الى مقتل سته اشخاص في منطقه مبدا
المنصوره بام درمان اثر سقوطي قذيفه
واظهرت لقطات مصوره تشييع الضحايا
الى شبكه مراسلنا من حي المعموره في جنوب
الخرطوم وراسي الجزيره محمد الطيب ومن ام
درمان حسن رزاق محمد ابدا معك اطلعنا على
اخر التطورات لاسيما القصف الاخير في جنوب
الخرطوم
تم عمليات القصف تمت والعمليات العسكريه
كانت تتركز في منطقه بحري الخرطوم بحري في
شارع المعونه وفي حله حمد هذه المناطق
بالتحديث الى تعبت من المناطق التي تطل
على القصر تطل على القصر الجمهوري من
ناحيه الغربيه فبالتالي ربما يسعى الجيش
السوداني لاعاده تمركزه على المناطق التي
تطل على الخرطوم وبالتالي ربما تكون شك من
اشكال التكتيك العسكري لمحاوله تطويق
الخرطوم بشكل او باخر بالنسبه للمناطق
الجنوبيه الخرطوم
نتحدث عن منطقه المعموره ومناطق الطائف
والكويت بالاضافه الى الصحافات لم تشهدين
الاشتباكات
الوضع كان ربما بالحذر المواطنين في هذه
المناطق
فبالتالي هذه المناطق شهدت سخونه في
الخرطوم بحري وانا ندري اذا كانت ستتواصل
الى الى مناطق اخرى اما الوضع الانساني
فهو وضع يزداد كل يوم تعقيدا
وتفاقما هناك خروج للمستشفيات من الخدمه
المحاله التجاريه لا تعمل كل هذه بصوره
كامله اما المناطق الاخرى مثل المخابز فهي
لا تعمل بصوره كبيره هناك عدد من المخابز
في عدد من المناطق لكن اغلبيه المحاله
التجاريه هي مقفله هناك حركه نشطه من
المواطنين في عدد من المناطق كل ما
ابتعدنا من
ساحه العمليات كلما كانت الحركه اكثر وكل
ما اقتربنا قلت وشله الحركه في هذه
المناطق نعم جلال حسن رزاق في ام درمان
كيف يتطور الوضع الانساني هناك
بالفعل اليوم كنا في جوله في عدد من
مستشفيات ام درمان هناك تداعيات انسانيه
مقلقه حقيقه بعض المستشفيات الكادر الطبي
الموجود فيها القدره التشغيليه له تقل عن
20% الكثير من الاطباء باتوا عالقين في
منازلهم بسبب استمرار المواجهات العسكريه
وبعض المستشفيات التي تعمل فقط للاطفال
باتت بشكل
تقدم العلاج لكافه الفئات العمريه باعتبار
انه الوصول للمستشفيات العامه باتا من
الصعوبه بمكان وايضا باعتبار ان الحركه
اصبحت صعبه على اي حال اليوم كنا في احد
مستشفيات ام درمان
والتقينا بعدد من المرضى وعدد من المصابين
جراء المواجهات العسكريه وايضا بالمسؤولين
في المستشفى الذين اشاروا الينا ان
الاطباء الذين ان يخدموا في في هذه الفتره
معظمهم عالقين في منازلهم لم يتمكنوا من
الوصول
لم يتمكنوا من الوصول وبالتالي هذا اصبح
ضغط كبير على الاطباء الذين
طلع عددهم واباتهم لانهم يستقبلون مرضى من
شتى الفئات العمريه لكن لم يتم الخدماتهم
ايضا ذهبنا الى مستشفى مخصص للاطفال هو
الذي تحول الى مستشفى عام ليستقبل كافه
المرضى يستقبل كافه الفئات العمريه خدمه
منه لتقديم الخدمات للذين لم يتمكنوا من
الوصول للمسيحات الخاصه على اي حال
التداعيات الانسانيه وخاصه القطاع الصحي
هو الاكثر المتضرر من هذه الازمه واذا
استمرت المواجهات العسكريه ايضا نقص
الامدادات الطبيه احد المستشفيات اغلق
الصيدليه التابعه له صيدليه الحكوميه
واضطر المرضى الى الذهاب الى الصبيان
الخاصه وايضا هي مغلقه وبالتالي شوح
الامدادات الطبيه مع استمرار الموجات
العسكريه تسبب في تداعيات انسانيه وصحيه
على كثير من المرضى ما لم يتم التوقف هذه
المواجهات بحسب ما اشاره الينا نعم شكرا
لكما حسن رزاق في ام درمان
ومحمد الطيب من حي المعموره في جنوب
الخرطوم
[موسيقى]
جاي من الخرطوم والوضع هناك قادم شديد
وبالمناسبه كده هذه الخانات والحبوبات
والاخوات خايفين وكده دي
اوريهم هو الوضع في صعوبه كده
قدام
المفيده دي وامبارح طبعا يوم العيد بالليل
كده دي حصلت حصلت ضرب كثير وفي اذى وادم
وبرضو في
اسمرار كثيره
والكهرباء عندنا نقاطعه شديد ولو في في
مجاعات مويه وكهرباء
وطعام والدجاج مقفله
[موسيقى]
مستشفى الامام عبد الرحمن المهدي مستشفى
اطفال يقع في المنطقه الجنوبيه ام درمان
وبيقدم خدماته للمنطقه من بانك حتى ممكن
الجبل الاولياء واحيانا
فالضغط عليه عالي جدا بسبب الظرفه الحالي
اللي انتم بتعرفوه كلكم طبعا
[موسيقى]
فالمستشفى التحول الى مستشفى عام او قواري
عامه
في مجال الجراحه في مجال الباطنيه في مجال
الاطفال انقاذ لحيات النصر
رغم الضغط العاديه لكن في النهايه انه
مكلفين او ملزمين بانه مقدم خدمات لانقاص
حياه الناس
[موسيقى]
[تصفيق]
لا حول ولا قوه الا بالله
واحد اتنين تلاته اربعه خمسه
لا حول ولا قوه الا بالله لا حول ولا قوه
الا بالله
لا حول ولا قوه الا بالله العلي العظيم لا
حول الله
من الخرطوم الباشا الطبيب الكاتب والمحلل
السياسي سيد الباشا كيف تفهمون دول لاجلاء
رعاياها من السودان في هذه المرحله
شكرا لك استاذنا الكريم
والتحيه لك ولقناه الجزيره وللشعب
السوداني
وعزي الضحايا هذه الحرب وعزل الاهل الذين
فقدوا ضحايا في هذا اليوم
والذين وقعت عليهم قاذفه من طائره في مبدا
المنصوره الذي راح ضحيتها سته اشخاص نزل
الله سبحانه وتعالى لهم الرحمه والمغفره
اقرا من هذه الزاويه
لسحب الدول
السودان افتكر انه هذه الدول تحتم فقط
برعايه ولا تهتم بشعب السوداني ولا تهتم
بهذا الصراع الدائر في السودان وقد تكون
هنالك
يعني قادمه في ظل في يعني المعارج وقد
تكون لهم معلومات بتطور المعارك في الايام
القادمه لذلك اصروا على على اجلاع ياهم من
السودان وترك سودانيين لحالهم يعني ضمير
هذا القتال وتستمر المعالجه الانسانيه
بدون
رحمه او رافا على الشعب السوداني وهذه
الدوائيه في المعايير نحن كنا نتمنى من
الدول من هذه الدول الصديقه للشعب
لتطور المعارك كما تفضلت المجتمع الدولي
يحذر من اندلاع حرب اهليه في حال تطورت
هذه المعارك
اذا تطورت هذه المعارك واستمرت بهذه
الكيفيه وهذه يعني بهذا الشكل الذي تدور
به الان سوف يعني
تتحرك نحو الحرب الاهليه والحرب الشامله
التي تشمل كل كل الولايات
الان نحن ندخل يعني اسبوع الثاني وحتى
الان
يعني على الارض
والحرب تدور داخل المواطنين داخل المواقع
الاقتصاديه ونحن نرى لامي
يتدمر والبنيه تحتيها للسودان الان تدمر
والشعب السوداني
يعاني ويلات هذه الحرب والمعالجه
الانسانيه الان تتفاقم الان بعض المواطنين
او كثير جدا من المواطنين النزوح من داخل
يعني داخل الخرطوم الى الولايات المجاوره
او الى مناطق قد تكون اكثر امنا من هذه
المناطق التي يعني يقتلون فيها رغم هذه
الاشتباكات العنيفه
يعني التصلب المواقف لانه برز اليوم
تصريحات من الطرفين تشير الى ضروره اللجوء
الى طاوله الحوار هل تشعرون ان الارضيه
مهيئه لهكذا سيناريو
اذا اذا كانت هنالك
الى الحوار او اللجوء يعني الى الحوار
ممكن يتحقق ذلك والان السيد الرئيس
البرهان هو يعني في يده مسؤوليه تاريخيه
الان
والوطن الان قد يعني ينفع
كم
الى يعني الى المرحله يعني الان بهذه
القرار ان يصدر قرار من جانب واحد ايقاف
هذه الحرب واذكد تماما اذا اصدر هذا
القرار سوف يلتزم الطرف الثاني بهذا
القرار من اجل مصلحه السودان ومن اين وحده
السودان ومن اجل تجنيب البلاد
الى يعني نحو نحو المجهول والى المستقبل
المظلم والمستقبل القادم الذي لا يستطيع
احد ان يتنبا له في مقبل الايام لكن الان
بيد البرهان ان يتخذ هذا القرار التاريخي
الذي يحفظ فيه دماء الشعب السوداني نحن
الان نرى ان لدي تقاتلونهم كلهم
اي قدر الدم تسيير هي غصبا على يعني
والان المعارك تدور في في
ايضا مزيد من الضحايا المدنيين يسقطون على
الطرقات
الباشا تضييق الكاتب والمحل السياسي في
الخرطوم
وفي حديث الطرفين عن خرق الهدنه اتهم
الفريق عبد المحمود حماد حسين نائب رئيس
هيئه الاركان للتدريب قوات الدعم السريع
بخرق الهدنه وخدمه اجنده دول خارجيه لحد
تعبيره
الهدنه ما بدات لذلك ما في ودنه
وعرفوا بالجبن وعرفوا بالاعتداء لا دين
ولا اخلاق اليوم
تشوفوا فيها
اجنده بتاع الدول الخارجيه الان الدول
الخارجيه تراجعتن قالوا دين منظمه ارهابيه
او بمجموعه بتاع العصابه الحراميه الناس
فيما تبقى من يوم يومين ان شاء الله نعلم
الخرطوم دي
جانبه نفى موسى خدام مستشار وقائد القوات
الدعم السريع في اتصال مع الجزيره
الاتهامته بخرق الهدنه ووقوع اي هجوم على
قياده الجيش والقصر الرئاسي
غير صحيح هذا الحديث
بدليل انه القوات الدعم السريعه قوات
الدعم السريع
او اقترحت هذه
لمده ان شاء الله ثلاثه ايام
كامل لم نرى منها اي خروقات او اي اعمال
تخريبيه مثل ما يجري من الطرف الاخر لم
نرى اي هجوم اليوم في
القياده او الغسل
اللواء المتقاعد محمد عجيب المدير السابق
للاعلام العسكري ينضم الينا من الخرطوم
اللواء عجيب تسريع وتيره اجلاء الرعايه
الاجانب هل يشير الى ان الجيش لم يحكم
السيطره بعد على الخرطوم كما قال المتحدث
باسم القوات المسلحه لانه اشار الى انه تم
اخماد ما وصفه بتمرد ميليشيا الدعم السريع
السلام عليكم ورحمه الله وبركاته
ان يشير
الاخلاء الرعايه الاجانب الى خارج الخرطوم
من قبل دولهم الى عدم صله القوات المسلحه
الامر في ارض الواقعه بالضروره بمكان
انتحرت الدول على حمايه رعاياها من اي
مخاطر امنيه او اي صراع عسكري ايا كانت
درجه هذه الصراع وايا كانت الطلبه لايه
طرف من الاطراف ولذلك اجزاء الرعايه
الاجانب من الخرطوم لا يشير الى طبيعه
الاحداث الجاريه اذا قدر انه يشير ويدل
على
تلك الدول على سلامه رعيات قراءه
من خلال مثل هذه الاعمال بغدر مع انه يتم
من خلال الشواهد والمشاهد التي تجري على
الارض
[موسيقى]
تصريحات عن ضروره جلوس كل السودانيين على
طاوله حوار لوقف هذه الازمه ماذا نفهم في
هذا الكلام بالتوقيت الحالي
بالعوده لعائلات الاحداث الى الوراء
محاوله الى حاله الوضع الى ما كان عليه
قبل اندلاع هذا القتال هذه الاصوات التي
تنادي بوقف القتال والجلوس كانت امامها
فرصه ذهبيه ومساحه واسعه لتقديم هذه
المقترحات وتجنيب البلاد الانزلاق في هذه
المزارع حتى السيد البرهان هو حتى السيد
برهان تحدث عن ضروره الجلوس على طاوله
حوار لحل هذه الازمه
تختلف البواعث والمنظورات السياسيه
والعسكريه لكل متحدث ثواني من قبل الفريق
البرهان او من قبل الاطراف المدنيه الفريق
البرهان يتحدث قطعا عن هذا الحوار من باب
السلامه الوطنيه ومن باب المسؤوليه
السياسيه والامنيه والوطنيه للبلاد ومن
باب تجنيب البلاد مخاطر الانزلاق بهذا
الامر بينما يظهر من خلال واقعي وسياسي
ماسوم في احاديث المدنيين الذين طالبون
بالتفاوض تمرير اجندات امنيه ومحاوله
انجاز حليفهم
ولكن المنطلقات والخلفيات تختلف بينهم
الحدث شكرا لك اللواء المتقاعد محمد عجيب
المدير السابق للعام العسكري في الخرطوم
مع دخول المعارك اسبوعها الثاني العمليات
العسكريه للجيش وقوات الدعم السريع تتركز
في العاصمه الخرطوم المنطقه الجنوبيه من
العاصمه تشهد عمليات تمشيط كما يصفها
الجيش السوداني المعارك في الجهه الجنوبيه
من الخرطوم اتخذت شكل حرب شوارع بسبب تحسن
مقاتلي الدعم السريع في الاحياء المناطق
الشماليه من الخرطوم والتحديدا الخرطوم
بحري وام درمان شهدت غارات جويه للجيش
السوداني رد عليها الدعم السريع باطلاق
المضادات الارضيه وفي منطقه
المسعوديه بين ولايتي الخرطوم والجزيره
نفى الجيش السوداني سيطره الدعم السريع
على مصنع جياد الذي يقع على طريق مدني
الرابط بين الخرطوم وولايه الجزيره
الجنوبيه ويبقى التركيز الكبير على وسط
الخرطوم الذي يشهد اشتباكات متقطعه
وتحديدا في محيط المطار والقصر الجمهوري
ومحيط القياده العامه للقوات المسلحه
قال الناطق الرسمي باسم الجيش السوداني
العميد نبيل عبد الله ان اجلاء البعثات
الاجنبيه سيجري خلال الساعات القادمه
واضاف في بيان ان الولايات المتحده
وبريطانيا وفرنسا والصين ستجلي
دبلوماسيينها بطائره نقل عسكريه تابعه
لقواتها المسلحه من الخرطوم ويتوقع الشروع
في ذلك فورا
وكانت قوه الدعم السريع اعلنت استعدادها
لفتح جميع مطارات السودان امام حركه
الملاحه الجويه بشكل جزئي لتمكين الدول
التي تريد اجلاء رعاياها من نقلهم بسلام
واضافت قوه الدعم السريع ان الخطوه تاتي
تماشيا مع الهدنه الانسانيه التي اعلنتها
لاثنتين وسبعين ساعه والتي بدات صباح
الجمعه سعيا لتسهيل حركه المواطنين
والمقيمين
هذا واعلنت وزاره الخارجيه السعوديه اجلاء
91 مواطنا سعوديا والسته وستين شخصا من
رعايه دول اخرى من السودان بينهم
دبلوماسيون وبثت وسائل اعلام سعوديه صورا
لوصول مواطنين سعوديين وعدد من رعايه
الدول الاخرى في السودان الى ميناء جده
على متن سفينه حربيه من الاسطول البحري
السعودي
في الاثناء قالت السفاره الامريكيه في
السودان انه ليس من الامن حاليا اجلاء
الرعايه الامريكيين في البلاد واضافت
السفاره في بيان ان هناك معلومات غير
كامله عن قوافل كبيره تغادر الخرطوم
متوجهه الى بول سودان لكن السفاره غير
قادره على مساعدتهم
في الاستراتيجيات العسكريه بجامعه بورتموس
والضابط السابق في المخابرات العسكريه
البريطانيه سيد فرانك ما هي المعوقات
والصعوبات في هكذا حاله في حرب مشابهه لما
يحدث الان في السودان خاصه في الخرطوم
امام اجلاء الرعايه الاجانب
بالنسبه للافراد التوقف العسكريه وطواقم
وزاره الخارجيه عاده يكون لديها عمليه
اجلاء او خطط عمليه اجلاء خارج اوضاع
الحرب والمعارك
ولدينا عمليات الاجلاء العاديه وغير
العاديه اذن هذا العمليه ستكون غير عاديه
وبالتالي ما يبحثون عنه هو نقطه
الاجلاء او نقطه نقطه اللقاء او تجمع
لهؤلاء
افراد الطواقم وبالنسبه لمدينه الخرطوم
اما يكون ذلك في المطار او في المرفق
ونتحدث عن مسافه بعيده الى المرفا او
الميناء بحسب معرفه فان المطار ليس
واقعا تحت السيطره بطريقه تسهل استخدامه
وباللمه صعب استعماله اذا يجب ايصال هؤلاء
الاشخاص الذين يجب اجلائهم الى نقطه
التجمع ودراسه مدى سلامه وامن اخراجهم من
خلال الطائرات هي امور ومسائل مطروحه
وصعبه الان تريص الولايات المتحده مثلا
السفاره الامريكيه في الخرطوم تقول بانه
من غير ممكن تامين سلامه رعاياها ودلمسيه
في حال ارادت الاجلاء الان كيف تفهمها علي
مؤشرات ودلالات على شيء ما في الخرطوم
على الوضع السياسي في الخرطوم ولكنني طبعا
انا اتفهم تردد الولايات المتحده
ممرات امنه لاجلاء هؤلاء ما الرساله التي
ارادها للمجتمع الدولي بتقديرك
نعم اتفهم
ان يتمنى الطرفان تعزيز المصداقيه
الوجود الاجنبي في الخرطوم
هل يمكنه هل يمكن لاي منهما او لكليهما
تامين ذلك من خلال تامين سلامه الطواقم لا
اعرف وربما احد الاطراف يريد ضمن السلامه
ويسعى الاخر الى تقويدها ولكن بالنسبه الى
موضوع التخطيط شخصيا انا لا اعتبر ان هذه
الضمانات يمكن ان نعتمد عليها
مع عدم احترام وقف اطلاق النار وانا اعتقد
ان هذا هو الامر المنطقي الذي يجب ان ننظر
به الى الامور عمليه اجلاء
مخطط لها
هي ما يجب او ما ننصح به ولكن طبعا حاليا
انا لست مخولا للحديث عن هذا الموضوع
الضابط السابق في المخابرات العسكريه
البريطانيه من اقصد شكرا لك
قال وزير الخارجيه الكويتيه الشيخ سالم
عبد الله الجابر الصباح ان بلاده نفذت
عمليه طارئه الاجلاء الكويتينا العالقين
في السودان واكد وزير الخارجيه الكويتي
وصول جميع الراغبين في العوده للبلاد الى
مدينه جده في السعوديه انه يجري العمل
حاليا على تامين نقلهم الى دوله الكويت
مددت سلطات مطار الخرطوم الدولي اغلاق
المجال الجوي حتى نهايه الشهر الحالي في
وقت تستعد فيه بعض الدول لاجلاء رعاياها
من السودان الولايات المتحده وبريطانيا
وضعت قوات وطائرات في حاله استعداد داخل
قواعد امريكيه في جيبوتي تحسبا لعمليه
اجلاء محتمله بحسب ما نقلت سكاي نيوز
البريطانيه سيناريوهات ونقاط الاجلاء
المحتمله نتابعها في التقرير التالي
يستمر مطار الخرطوم موقع اشتباك بين الجيش
السوداني وقوه الدعم السريع ولهذا مددت
سلطات المطار اغلاق المجال الجوي السوداني
حتى الثلاثين من الشهر الحالي فما هي اذا
النقاط التي يمكن استخدامها كنقاط اجلاء
نظريا جوا يمكن الاعتماد على مطار دونجل
الدولي وهو مطار داخلي يقع شمالي البلاد
بالقرب من الحدود المصريه مطار الشهيد
الصبيره وهو مطار مدني داخلي يقع في مدينه
الجنينه غربيه السودان مطار بورتسودان
الدولي يقع في ولايه البحر الاحمر محاذيا
لمدينه جده اما برا فيمكن اعتماد طريق بري
الى الولايات المحاذيه لاثيوبيا ومصر
وجنوب السودان وهي دول ما زالت حدودها
البريه مفتوحه مع السودان وتعتبر الاكثر
امنا
فكيف تسير عمليه الاجلاء من الواضح ان
جيبوتي المجاوره تحولت نقطه اهتمام لبعض
الدول الولايات المتحده الامريكيه نقلت
قوات بالفعل اليها تحسبا للتحرك لاجلاء
رعاياها واورددت وسائل اعلام بريطانيه
معلومات تفيد بان لندن وضعت قوات وطائرات
في وضع استعداد في قواعد عسكريه لدول
حليفه لها الولايات المتحده وفرنسا في
جيبوتي ومن غير المعلن بشكل قاطع حتى الان
ما اذا كانت لندن وواشنطن ستلجاان لعمليات
انقاذ هجينه لاجلاء رعايهما الى جيبوتي
ومنها جوا ام ان العمليه قد تتضمن دخول
جنود برا الى اراضي السودان
كذلك فعلت اليابان وكوريا الجنوبيه اللتان
ارسلت طائرات نقل واطقم طبيه الى جيبوتي
اما الاتحاد الاوروبي فيقول انه يتابع عن
كثب تطورات الاوضاع انتظارا للحظه
المناسبه لبدء عمليه الاجلاء
بعض البعثات بدات فعلا عمليات الاجلاء
سلكت البعثه الدبلوماسيه السعوديه طريقا
بريا من الخرطوم الى بورسودان ومن هناك
بحرا الى جده الاردن بدوره شرع في تنفيذ
خطه اجلاء لبعثته قد تسلك المسار ذاته اما
البعثه الايطاليه فتوجه بعض افرادها برا
الى بورسودان ومنها جوا الى مصر
[موسيقى]
السيد كاميرا
مستشار المبعوث الامريكي السابق الى
السودان ومسؤول شؤون افريقيا السابق في
البيت الابيض منضم الينا من واشنطن
تسريع وتيره اجلاء الرعايه الاجانب من
السودان هل يؤشر الى توسع الاشتباكات
وتطورها في الساعات المقبله
الحقيقه لا اعرف اذا ما كانت الوتيره سوف
تتسارع هناك الكثير من الحديث حول هذه
النقطه ولكن لم نرى اي اجراءات ايل الى
الاجلاء حاليا بالنسبه الى الامريكيين
والاوروبيين هم لم يتمكنوا كما اشرتم من
القيام والمباشره بهذه العمليات هناك
مشاكل مرتبطه بسلامه وبامن هذه العمليات
اذا الوتيره لم تتسارع ويبدو من الواضح ان
السفارات الغربيه بما في ذلك سفاره
الولايات المتحده الامريكيه لديها مخاوف
مرتبطه
بالاجلاء البري بسبب النقاط المختلفه على
طرق هناك خطر باختطاف عدد من
الدبلوماسيين لذلك هناك دراسه للطرق التي
يمكن ان تستخدم والسفاره الامريكيه اعرف
انها تبحث في
الاجلاء جوا ولكن الوصول الى المطار هو
امر خطر لذلك
هناك نظر بامكانيه استخدامي الهليكوبتر
ولكن ما من اجراءات حاليا لاجلاء الرعايه
تركيز الجهود في الساعات الحاليه او حتى
في الساعات المقبله كما تبعنا في التقرير
على الاجلاء كيف يمكن ان ينعكس على الجهود
الدوليه والضغوط الدوليه لوقفه اطلاق
النار بين طرفي الصراع
في الحقيقه بالنسبه الى ضغوط المفروضه على
الفريقين اعتقد ان الطاقه تصرف الان في
واشنطن وفي اماكن اخرى على عمليه الاجلاء
وليس على عمليه الضغط بشكل مباشر على
الطرفين اذا الدبلوماسيين الامريكيين اولا
وبعد ذلك اجلاء الرعايه الاجانب والتاكد
من ان المدنيين السودانيين يصلون الى بر
الامان وايصال المساعدات الانسانيه هذه هي
الاولويات القصوى الان بالنسبه الى وقف
اطلاق النار وبنسبه الى الاتفاق السياسي
اعتقد ان ما تركز عليه واشنطن هو محاوله
منع او محاوله مشاركه دول اخرى مصر تشاد
ليبيا منع هذه الدول من الانخراط في
النزاع كي لا يتوسع هذا النزاع ولكن
بالنسبه الى واشنطن تفهم ان كلا الطرفين
لا يودان ان عن القتال هما يعربان عن
النيه بالتوقف عن القتال ولكن هذا غير
صحيح ولا احد يصدق ما يقولانه بالنسبه الى
وقف اطلاق النار اذا النيه الان هي
بالاستمرار بالقتال والان يجب التجهيز
لعمليه اجلاء الرعايه وما خطوره تحول هذا
هذا النزاع الى حرب اهليه كما تحذر جهات
دوليه سيد هاتسن
نعم هذا في غايه الخطوره في غايه الخطوره
وايضا هناك خطر كبير على الرعايه الاجانب
والموظفين الخارجي بالاضافه الى الشعب
السوداني هناك خطر ان الرعايه الاجانب
يمكن ان يصبحوا رهاء هذه هي المخاوف التي
تنتشر في واشنطن وفي اماكن اخرى في عواصم
اخرى خصوصا واننا راينا في الايام الاخيره
هناك
خرق
لحرب السفارات مختلفه وهناك هجمات تعرضت
لها بعثات دبلوماسيه اصلا وخصوصا السفارات
الغربيه في السودان ولذلك هناك قلق منتشر
في اوساط الدبلوماسيين اذا ما تمت عمليه
الاجلاء برا هناك خطر الاستهداف كذلك شكرا
الى السودان في واشنطن
نعود للتفكير بالمشهد الميداني فقد افاد
مراسل الجزيره بعوده القصف والسماع يدوي
في جارات عنيفه تبعها تصاعد السن النيران
في الخرطوم بحري التي شهدت معارك عنيفه في
مناطق متفرقه هذا اليوم وقال مراسل
الجزيره ان قوات الدعم السريع استخدمت
المضادات الارضيه للتصدي للهجمات المستمره
منذ الصباح ونقل عن تلك القوات انها تتصدى
للعديد من هجمات الجيش التي يستهدف
مواقعها واضاف ان سلاح الجو التابعه للجيش
السوداني كان حاضرا في تلك المواجهات
هذه الصور مباشره اذا لهذا القصف الاخير
والسنه النيران التي لا زالت تتصاعد في
منطقه الخرطوم بحري التي كما اسلفنا شهدت
معارك عنيفه في مناطق متفرقه
ذكر مصدر دبلوماسي للجزيره ان بريطانيا
تدعو الى عقد جلسه طارئه ومفتوحه لمجلس
الامن بشان السودان في اقرب وقت ممكن بعد
عطله عيد الفطر لمناقشه التطورات في
السودان
السفير البريطاني السابق في السودان ينضم
الينا من لندن السفير كي ما هو التقييم
البريطاني
للازمه السودانيه حاليا بتشعباتها
العسكريه الميدانيه
نحن نتحدث عن نزاع خطر للغايه وهناك خطر
بان يتمدد هذا النزاع ويتوسع ويزيد من
معاناه الشعب السوداني الذي كان يعاني
بشكل كبير منذ سنوات ان الخطر يمكن ان
يتمدد الى الدول الجاره للسودان في
المنطقه وطبعا هناك خطر
على الموظفين الدوليين المتواجدين في
البلاد في الايام الاولى لهذه المواجهه
بين قوات الدعم السريع والجيش السوداني
كان هناك محاولات للضغط على الطرفين لوقف
اطلاق النار اليوم يبدو بانها تراجعت هذه
الجهود لماذا بتقديرك
في الحقيقه اعتقد ان الرساله التي تصل من
المجتمع الدولي وهنا نتحدث عن البلدان
الجاره للسودان بلدان المنطقه بالاضافه
الى المجتمع الدولي باسره الامم المتحده
والاتحاد الافريقي الصوت كان موحدا منذ
البدايه الدعوه الى وقف الاقتتال والتوصل
الى وقفا لاطلاق النار وان يعود الطرفان
الى طاوله المفاوضات والى العمليه
السياسيه الاليه الى الانتقال الى حكومه
مدنيه اعتقد ان رساله الدوليه في غايه
الوضوح منذ بدايه هذا النزاع وهو صوت موحد
على الساحه الدوليه وهذه الدعوات تستمر
واعتقد ان الدعوات استمرت حتى يومنا هذا
التوصل الى وقف لاطلاق النار لكي يتمكن من
يريد ان يغادر الخرطوم والسودان بشكل عام
ان يغادر وحتى الشعب السوداني لكي يصل الى
المستشفيات ويؤمن الطعام والماء ولكي
يتمكن من الخروج من العاصمه ومن مناطق
النظام وبالتالي هناك
مطالب انسانيه كذلك توجه الى طرفي النزاع
لاحترام الشعب السوداني القوات المسلحه
يجب ان تحمي الشعب السوداني عوض عن قتل
الشعب السوداني في مدنه ولكن كل هذه
الدعوات حتى الان لم تلقى اذان صاغيه منها
دعوات الرباعيه التي بريطانيا هي طرف فيها
لماذا يفشل حتى الان المجتمع الدولي
بممارسه الضغوط على الطرفين لوقفه الاقدار
او حتى على حثهم للالتزام بالهدن التي
تعلن
اعتقد اننا نتحدث عن
الجنرلين
السودانيين الجنرال الحميطي
والجنرال البرهان هما المساله ويتعين
عليهما ان يتخذ القرارات الصائبه وان يلقي
السلاح هما لا يتصرفان بهذا الشكل بل
يحاولان ان يعزز المكاسب المحققه ولا
يصغيان الى الاسره الدوليه ولكن هناك
مؤشرات بدات تظهر بانهما على استعداد
لتيسير وتسهيل عمليه اجلاء الرعايه
الاجانب من الخرطوم واود ان اهنئ المملكه
العربيه السعوديه على تمكنها من اجلاء عدد
كبير من الرعايه بالاضافه الى الاردنيين
والكويتيين الذين تمكنوا من المباشره بهذه
العمليات
واامل انه في الساعات المقبله وفي الايام
المقبله البعثات الاخرى سوف تتمكن من
المغادره نيكل سكاي السفير البريطاني
السابق في السودان شكرا لك
ومع استمرار المواجهات زاد العبء على
المستشفيات في السودان فهناك نقص كبير في
الكوادر الصحيه وفي المواد الطبيه
والادويه
[موسيقى]
اما سليمان فيروي تفاصيل مؤلمه عن تعرضه
لاكثر من رصاصه طائشه وشظايا سببت له
جروحا بالغه
هنا كده
لغايه ثاني
وصلوني هنا المستشفى
الحمد لله كويس يحتضن هذا المستشفى العام
العديد من الجرحى والمرضى في ظل نقص كبير
في الكوادر الطبيه الذين ظلوا عالقين في
منازلهم جراء استمرار المواجهات المسلحه
وصارت القدره التشغيليه للمستشفى من اطباء
الطوارئ اقل من 20% في الكادر الطبي
المناوب يعني في كادر موجود بالمستشفى مني
يوم السبت هم البعالجوا المرضى
في مشاكل بانه نحن اصلا ما لاقين طريق
نجيب الكادر يعني حتى لو في كادر موجود
احنا ما لاقيين طريقه ننقل من المنطقه
نجيبوا للحد المشفى هنا
فمعظم مشاكلنا مشاكل بتاع كاذب والكادر
الموجود ذاته بالمستشفى اللي هو مناوب من
يوم السبت او جبناه في الايام اللي فاتت
دي يعني تمام تظلل المستشفيات اكثر
القطاعات تاثرا بطبيعه الحرب في العاصمه
الخرطوم فقد اعلنت نقابه الاطباء ان حوالي
70% من المستشفيات المتاخمه لمناطق
الاشتباك متوقفه عن الخدمه كما تعرضت
عربات اسعاف لاعتداءات واعيق بعضها عن
المرور لنقل المرضى وايصال المعونات
استمرار المواجهات المسلحه سيتسبب في اثار
كارثيه على النظام الصحي الذي كان يصارع
اساسا قبل الازمه الراهنه وسط نداءات
تتعالى بمساعده المرضى والمتضررين حسن
رزاق الجزيره انظرما
من القاهره السيد ريتشارد برانان مدير
الطوارئ للمكتب الاقليمي بمنظمه الصحه
العالميه صيد ما تقييمكم للوضع الصحي
والوضع الانساني في السودان
في الحقيقه نحن نتحدث عن ازمه كبيره في
السودان على المستوى الصحي هناك صعوبه
كبيره وهناك مستويات مرتفعه من العنف
والتي ادت الى اكثر من 420 او 430 قتيل
باضافه الى اكثر من 3000 جريح وهناك عدد
كبير من الاشخاص الذين تاثروا ولم يتم
احترام الهدنه ان وزاره الصحه تقول لنا
انا فقط 17% من المنشات الصحيه منشات
الرعايه الصحيه لا تزال عامله وهناك مشاكل
مرتبطه بالهجمات التي تعرضت لها منشات
الصحه بالاضافه الى نقص الامن والسلامه
وغياب الامن والسلامه وعدم قدره الاطباء
والممرضين والممرضات من الوصول الى
المستشفيات والنقص في الامدادات الطبيه
والادويه والاكسجين والم بالاضافه الى عدم
قدره الناس على الوصول الى المستشفيات
وبالتالي نحن نتحدث عن وضع في غايه
الصعوبه وهناك قلق كبير بالنسبه الى
الظروف المحيطه
بهذه
المنطقه وهناك ايضا بعض الامراض المزمنه
والناس الذين يعادون من مرض الكلى على
سبيل المثال الذين هم بمحاجه بحاجه الى
مساعدات مستمره او النساء الحوامل التي هن
بحاجه الى الوصول الى بيئه فيها امن
وسلامه الى اخره الوضع صعبا للغايه والناس
ليس باستطاعتهم ان يصلوا الى الخدمات
الصحيه التي هم بحاجه اليها سيد ريتشارد
حتى الان
الاشتباكات تتركز في مناطق محدده ومعينه
ما امكانيه ادخال مساعدات عبر الحدود
البريه مع السودان مثلا
في الحقيقه ان التحدي الاكبر بالنسبه الى
ايصال المساعدات الانسانيه وانعدام الامن
بالنسبه الى منظمه الصحه العالميه هي لا
تزال تعمل نحن لا نزلنا نعمل في الميدان
بالرغم من العنف ولقد قمنا بتوزيع
المساعدات الطبيه
للاطقم في اماكنها مختلفه وقمنا بتوزيع
هذه المؤنة وطبعا كنا نتوقع التصعيد
ولكننا لم نكن نتوقع ان ينتشر النزاع الى
هذا الحد وبالتالي هذا المخزون بدا يتراجع
ولكن في الايام الاخيره تمكنا من التامين
الوقود للمستشفيات
والعياداتي في الخرطوم ونحاول ان نصل الى
المخزون في الخرطوم حيث لدينا المزيد من
المعدات وبالتالي نحاول ان نصل ايضا الى
المخزن في
بورتسودان اذا اذا ما سمحت الظروف الامنيه
واللوجستيه سوف نتابع العمل على توزيع هذه
الامدادات
بالتنسيقي مع وزاره الصحه على المستشفيات
والعيادات المختلفه ولدينا 42 طن من
الامدادات
الاغاثه العاجله وما ان نتمكن من ادخالها
الى السودان سوف نقوم بذلك ولكن المشكله
الاساسيه الان هي انعدام الامن وهو ما
يعرقل وصول المساعدات الانسانيه وعلى طرفي
النزاع ان يتوقفاه عن القتال ويوقفال
اعمال العدائيه للسماحي للمنظمات
الانسانيه ومنظمات الاغاثه من مثلي منظمه
الصحه العالميه بايصال المساعدات لمن هم
بحاجه شكرا مدير الطوارئ المكتب الاقليميه
بنظره الصحه العالميه
قال مدير برنامج الغذاء العالمي في تشاد
بيير اونورات انه يتوقع موجات اخرى من
اللاجئين السودانيين ان البرنامج مستعد
لاستقبال 100 الف شخص واضاف المتحدث ان
عمال الاغاثه يواجهون تحديات توفير المياه
للاجئ
اعظم حاجه لدينا اليوم هي الماء هؤلاء
الذين قدموا بمؤونه لا تكفي الا لايام
اعتقدوا انهم لن يكونوا هنا سوى لايام
قليله لذا على عاتقنا اليوم ان نتدخل وقد
راينا عمال الرعايه الصحيه يقدمون لهم
الدعم ولدينا قافله شاحنات غادرت جميله
هذا اليوم وتحمل 340 طنا من الغذاء ما
يكفي لاطعام عشره الاف شخص لشهرين
خيارات صعبه تواجه المدنيين في السودان
فافق الحل السلمي يكاد يكون غائبا والامن
معدوم والخوف مستبد والظروف المعيشيه من
سيء الى اسوا خيارات مواجهه هذا الواقع
تتلخص اما في النزوح الى ولايه ومدن اقل
توترا او اللجوء الى الخارج وهذه خيارات
ليست متاحه للجميع
مع دخول المواجهات المسلحه في السودان
اسبوعها الثاني وتوالي الاعلان عن هدن لا
تكاد تبدا حتى تخرق وتفاقم الازمه
المعيشيه المترتبه على المواجهات وصعوبه
الوصول الى الماء والغذاء لم يعد النزوح
امام هذا الواقع خيارا لكثير من
السودانيين بل اصبح ضروره مكتب الامم
المتحده للتنسيق الشؤون الانسانيه في اخر
تقاريره عن السودان تحدث عن زياده كبيره
في موجات النزوح من جميع انحاء ولايه
الخرطوم وجهه النازحين الهاربين بارواحهم
من مناطق القتال ولاياته ومناطق اقل توترا
واكثر هدوءا ووفره في حاجيات العيش البسيط
ولايات الجزيره وسنار والنيل الابيض ونهر
النيل والقضارف كانت الخيار الاول لسكان
الخرطوم الكبرى اما في ولايه شمال
كورتوفان فقد نزح نحو ثمانيه الاف شخص من
مدينه الاوبيض التي يشهد مدارها والبطاقه
المحيطه به مواجهات عنيفه منذ اسبوع
ولجاوا الى مدن اخرى داخل الولايه
كما تحدثت المنظمه الدوليه للهجره عن نزوح
واسع النطاق للمواطنين من مدينه الفاشر
بولايه شمال دارفور دون تقديم ارقام مفصله
والارقام الدقيقه للنازحين بعد اخر من
ابعاد الماساه فبدونها لا تستطيع المنظمه
الدوليه تقدير حجم المساعدات التي يحتاجها
النازحون فضلا عن الكابوس اللوجستي
المتمثل في ايصالها الى محتاجها في ظل
استمرار اغلاق المجال الجوي للبلاد
والتهديد المستمر لسلامه موظف الاغاثه
الدوليين والمحليين اما سكان المناطق
الحدوديه فقد كانت الحدود قبلتهم وهو خيار
غير متاح لسكان الولايات الداخليه وحسب
مفوضيه الامم المتحده للاجئين فقد لجا ما
بين عشره الاف الى عشرين الف مواطن سوداني
الى تشاد المجاوره معظمهم نساء واطفال
وتخشى الدول المجاوره للسودان من طول امد
الازمه فاستمرارها يعني تدفق اعداد كبيره
من اللاجئين على حدودها وهذه منطقه في
افريقيا
تضم دولا يتراوح وضعها امنيا واقتصاديا
بين الناميه والهشه ولا تستطيع الكثير
منها تلبيه حاجيه سكانها فضلا عن استقبال
اعداد كبيره من اللاجئين
ما المعلومات التي لديكم حول لجوء مزيد من
السودانيين الى تشاد
بحسب
هو موجود في الواقع الان فان الاف
السودانيين خاصه من المناطق الحدوديه
مع تشات يفرون من السودان باتجاه الاراضي
الشعبيه خاصه في ولايه غرب الدارفور من
من الجنينه وكذلك في مناطق اخرى قربي من
الحدود الشعبيه مع افريقيا الوسطى ومع
السودان تحدثت مع مسؤول الصليب الاحمر في
منطقه وهي منطقه حدوديه السودان تحدث وقال
انهم يقدرون عدد اللاجئين السودانيين
الذين وصلوا الى كات خلال الايام الماضيه
في منطقه ادري لوحدها يصل الى نحو 7000
لاجئ سوداني معظمهم من الاطفال والنساء
هؤلاء ين الى نحو 400 الف
شخصانيون فروا من الحروب التي وقعت في
دارفور منذ
ثلاثه
مستعده
للتعامل
المطربه في السودان وشكل
سته اعضاء من الحكومه بالاضافه الى مختلف
الاجهزه الامنيه وايضا تستعد لايواء مزيد
من اللاجئين وكذلك المنظمات الانسانيه
العامله في اعجاب تتحدث عن ان هذه العدد
الان الذي يفت الى تشاد من اللاجئين هو
يشابه الوضع الذي كان عليه الوضع الحدود
بين ايجاد والسودان خلال بدايه ازمه
دارفور في 2003
الاستعدادات حتى الان على عدم وثائق
بالنسبه للمنظمات الانسانيه وبدات في
تسيير قوافل من اجل اعداد قيام للاجئين
الذين وصلوا خلال الايام الماضيه لكن حتى
الان مازال اللاجئين يقيمون تحت الاشجار
ولا ليتوفر لديهم حتى الان اي قيام وكذلك
الاطعمه التي الان بدات المنظمات
الانسانيه خاصه برنامج الغذاء العالمي
توفيرها للاجئين الذين وصلوا وتم
التسبيتهم شكرا
في السودان تفضل عبد الرزاق بن جميل شكرا
لك
وقد قدر مكتب الامم المتحده لتنسيق الشؤون
الانسانيه اوتشا ان نحو 16 مليون سوداني
بحاجه الى مساعدات خلال العام الجاري
تزامن ذلك مع تحذير منظمات انسانيه دوليه
من حدوث كارثه انسانيه جراء استمرار
الاشتباكات بين الجيش وقوات الدعم السريع
وقالت تلك المنظمات ان وضع السكان الصعب
اصلا اخذ في التفاقم مع احتدام المعارك
لا تفتش هنا عن العيد فلن ترى ابتسامه على
الوجوه بل سترى مزيدا من السودانيين يفرون
بارواحهم كل يوم انهم يفرون نزوحا او
لجوءا لا من المعارك وحدها وانما ايضا من
واقع انساني مزرع لم يضبط تماما على توقيت
الاقتتال
فقبل اندلاع الصراع المسلح بين الجيش
وقوات الدعم السريع كانت التقديرات
الامميه تنبه وتحذر
اذ كان نحو ثلث سكان السودان يعانون
بالفعل الجوع الشديد فماذا ستفعل تطورات
الراهنه بالسودانيين بعد وقد بلغت
احتياجاتهم الانسانيه اعلى مستوياتها
للعام الثالث على التوالي
اجججت اعمال القتال مخاوف من تفاقم الوضع
الانساني في بلد يعد بين الافقر في العالم
شح الغذاء والماء وتذبذبت امدادات الوقود
والكهرباء وتدهورت منظومه الصحه
زيد على ذلك هجمات لا تستثني البنيه
التحتيه المدنيه كانظمه المياه والصرف
الصحي والمرافق الصحيه والمدارس
في نشرته الاحداث يشير المكتب الامامي
لتنسيق الشؤون الانسانيه اوتشا الى حاجه
ما يقرب من 16 مليون شخص في السودان الى
مساعدات خلال العام الجاري والى معاناه
اربعه ملايين طفل دون سن الخامسه ونساء
حوامل سوء التغذيه الحاج والى ان ما يصل
الى احد عشر مليون شخص ليس لديهم ما يكفي
من الطعام
تصاعد العنف في السودان يعرض ملايين
الاطفال للخطر تقول منظمه اليونسيف انها
ماساه مضاعفه بالنسبه للعديد من الاسر
العالقه في مرمى النيران
الصليب الاحمر الدولي حذر من نفاذ الماء
والطعام لدى المحاصرين في مواقع المواجهات
والمواجهات المسلحه عقدت ما تعرف
بالتدخلات المنقذه للحياه والتغذيه
الوقائيه
اذ تعطلت خطه الامم المتحده للاستجابه
الانسانيه والتي تستهدف ملايين السودانيين
كما حيل دون العمليات المشتركه بين وزاره
الصحه السودانيه ومنظمات غير حكوميه
وشركاتها من وكالات الامم المتحده تقول
تلك المنظمات ان تقديم الدعم يستوجب ضمان
امن موظفيها وسلامتهم ذاك من حقها لكن من
يضمنه اليوم للسودانيين انفسهم